- Alright y'all, it's
time to scroll through the
busy and bountiful pages,
bountiful, you can't say that word enough,
of social media to share something sure
to brighten your day or hopefully it does.
This is what I'm liking.
(upbeat music)
On this, the International
Day of the Girl,
I want to tell you about
nine-year-old Ayla.
Two years ago, she developed
a deep passion for running.
As much as she loved it,
she didn't make her school's
all star cross-country team;
but she didn't let it knock her down.
Instead, she found another
team in town and worked,
and practiced, and worked, and practiced.
Now she's a bonafide
record-breaking track star.
That's the kind of drive that's led
to Mira and Valeria to success.
But with Ayla, it's not even
what makes her extraordinary.
Ayla was born without her fibula,
and her lower leg was
amputated when she was two.
We have Ayla and her mom, Laura,
on the line right now. What's up y'all?
(audience cheering)
Hello! So what is it, Ayla?
What is it about running
that you love so much?
- I love running with my friend
and I am really competitive
and I love racing.
- That's amazing, Ayla, a great job.
So you're now competing
in huge races, right?
- Yes.
- I'll brag on her a little bit.
She has done some national races
with her club team against typical kids.
And she's medaled at some
of these national races.
And then this past summer,
she decided she wanted
to try adapted racing.
So she's competing against
kids that are similar to her,
and she qualified for junior nationals.
And in July, she went
out to junior nationals,
won a bunch of gold medals,
and actually broke
three U.S. track records
for her age and disability type.
- That's incredible, Ayla!
I hope you are so proud
of yourself. That's an
amazing thing to accomplish.
So, Ayla, you say that there's
an important lesson here, right?
- Yes, the important lesson is
if you want to try out a sport,
you're not always going
to like it at first,
because you got to practice,
practice, practice.
If you don't like it,
you don't have to force yourself to do it.
You can just stop and
find a different sport
that you can try.
- Yeah. I love sports, though.
It teaches you so many things.
It's more than just the actual sport.
It does teach you a lot of things
mentally, emotionally,
teamwork, all of that.
But I'm so proud of you, Ayla,
congratulations. Thank you, Laura.
Thank y'all for your time.
I'm liking your posts, right now.
(doorbell ring)
And that's not all. Our
season long partner,
Pilot pen, the go-to pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show
wants to honor ultimate overachievers
just like you, Ayla. So they'll be using
their G2 gel ink pen to write you a check
for $1,000. How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
I think Laura got the most excited.